justice was definitely served i just
watched the president of the united
states give a speech
and one thing stood out he said
shouldn't take this long
to get justice i'm glad justice was
served
i'm happy for the family happy for the
lawyers i'm really happy for
stephen jackson stack five you know
there's a good friend of mine that was
his
close friend and he was really one of
the first guys to lead the charge and
and you know demanding justice but
justice was served and we still have a
long time ago
the fact that we're sitting there not
knowing what's going to happen
yeah that still means we have a long way
to go
we expected that you know the outcome
was going to be like this but
we've expected that a lot of times and
then outcome was different
i was just saying to myself i hope they
do the right thing because if they don't
they're going to tear this mother up
because
we're tired we demand the justice we got
it
i'm happy for the family but we still
have a long way to go
this is you know mines like uh you know
you don't
you celebrate it but we still got a lot
of room
to grow and you know we still have to
get get rid of systematic racism yeah
still a lot of that stuff going on and
again i'm happy for the family and you
know the verdicts or
you know everything was done correctly
but we still have a long way to go
a sense of relief duane yeah i i know i
speak for
a lot of people in the world when i say
i was sitting in front of the tv
watching a verdict come down
and my hands started sweating
my body started shivering and my heart
started pounding
because i was nervous i was nervous
because i didn't believe
right i'm sitting in front of tv and i
didn't believe and even even when
the verdict came down and and all
charges
um you know that we wanted was met
i still was staring at the tv listening
to the judge because i was
i was thinking that it was an outcoming
because we've never seen this
you know and so today
showed to me the the power of community
today it gave us some sort of
we seen some sort of ability to see
change right
and if there was any win today like shaq
said this wasn't you can't celebrate
this but if it was any win today
to me it was a win for accountability
that's the only win today was a win for
accountability and so
you know we have to continue to keep
george floyd's family
lifted up in our prayers we have to
continue to pray for healing
for the black community across the world
and to me
we got more work to do yeah we all know
that it's more work to do
and so the work is not done but today
was definitely
a good day to see accountability have as
justice
have his moment i think today
i like to flip channels because i think
today we
we only listen and we only hear we only
reach out to the people that agree with
what we agree
and speak our same language and so i
like to go through
different tv shows and and hear um
what everybody thought about today i
think
one quote that stuck out to me was van
jones when he said
i woke up afraid to hope today and it's
not okay when you wake up afraid to hope
i also think just bringing this all
together of the community
we're sitting here on a sports show
speaking about justice and speaking
about things that are going on within
our courts system
it's not okay to just be a bystander of
justice or our political system
or democracy and i think democracy we
think of as a destination and it's a
continuous journey
and it has to be thought of that way and
just because we're athletes
just because we're stay-at-home moms or
businessmen or
doctors or lawyers whatever we are like
we have to
actively participate in that because if
we don't we're not doing our job and
we're failing
the generation that comes after us and i
just think you look at the past and how
many people
before had to die and had to not receive
justice for this to happen today
and i just think we can't we can't
we can't hide behind badges money power
race gender we can't hide behind those
things because that's not justice
and we're lying to ourselves we continue
to think that so although this was a
step
in the right direction i think it's
really about
accountability but it's also
understanding that like this isn't
it there's far more trials that are
going
other directions that shouldn't that
don't that aren't just and so
yes this is a step in the right
direction we still have so much more to
go